madame monsieur bonsoir y at-il une
limite à l'horreur et à la folie humaine
réponse non si on en croit les dernières
informations qui nous parviennent du
rwanda où les massacres de civils et
notamment d'enfants se multiplient le
dernier dans un faubourg de kigali
semble avoir touché certains des
orphelins dont vous avez découvert la
détresse avec un reportage réalisé par
l' agence capa et diffusée dans notre
magazine envoyé spécial le 26 mai
commentaires gilles rabin une fois déjà
des miliciens hutus ont forcé la porte
de son église pour y massacrer des
réfugiés tutsis que le père blanchard
croyait pouvoir protéger ils le
croyaient
parce que ces réfugiés étaient des
enfants de très jeunes enfants tous
orphelins ont pu alors j'ai les prises
et personne ne m'a rien dit on est resté
ensemble
seuls ceux là ils avaient réussi à les
sauver du premier massacre ce soir selon
toute vraisemblance ils sont morts
assassinés par les mêmes miliciens qui
sont revenus hier après-midi dans
l'église du père blanchard chercher leur
ration de victimes
ce reportage d'envoyé spécial qu'ils
étaient un cri de détresse
l'appel au secours d'un père blanc qui
refusait de quitter le rwanda pour
sauver ses 50 orphelins et qui savait
déjà qu'un jour les peurs reviendrai
c'était il ya plus d'un mois personne
n'est venu au secours d'hiver blanchard
ni l'armée rwandaise qui a refusé
d'intervenir au moment où ils ont
défoncé la porte de son église ni les
casques bleus
tout occupé à se protéger eux-mêmes
avant dieu croire en l'homme peut-être
croire en l'homme qui n'est plus divisé
le crainte je vois c'est qu'il s'est
passé